[Applaudissements]
marcos c'est bien que ce soit la soirée
en plus ça tombe bien puisque je vous
lance dans l'imitation
ah merde non mais je maîtrise de plein
droit j'ai bossé comme un dangereux par
exemple genre tu sais faire je parle
politique
vas-y françois hollande alors faisons de
une année de vaillance et d'espérance et
c'est dans cet esprit que je vous
adresse du fond de mon coeur mes
meilleurs voeux
alors non c'est pourri donc je te dire
entre potes mais vraiment ce que le
seigneur les dictateurs c'est ça un vrai
métier quand tu vois franchement le truc
le plus dur je pense c'est plus original
c'est chanter avec la bonne une femme
ah oui comme michael gregorio oui oh moi
tu vois pas oui c'est moi un truc facile
genre céline dion céline dion
[Musique]
à
alors non pas des mots sur pas de voix
sérieux maintien il faut en fait il faut
les trucs originaux genre j'hallucine ou
sidéris jockey d'un café voilà on va
bosser
ouais ouais
[Applaudissements]